اسمحوا لي أن أكون واضحا حقا بشأن هذا ما
السيد.  فعل ماشاب ليس له أي علاقة على الإطلاق بالتحقيق الجماعي
الذي أعتقد أنه تم التعامل مع الملف
بشكل غير لائق من قبل مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي ، وأعتقد أنه تم استخدامه بشكل غير لائق
وتقديمه إلى محكمة قانون مراقبة الاستخبارات الأجنبية (FISA) ، وهذه
قضية منفصلة عن
التحقيق الجماعي لمنظمة ترامب
فيما يتعلق بروسيا.
الوقت ليسوا متصلين بأي شكل
من الأشكال السبب الوحيد السيد.  يمكن استبعاد مولر من أي وقت مضى
لأنني لا أرى أي
سبب عندما يتعلق الأمر بالسيد.  مولر
يحتاج إلى أن يكون قادرًا على أداء وظيفته
بشكل مستقل عن أي نفوذ سياسي
تعهد به للشعب الأمريكي بصفته
جمهوريًا للتأكد من أن السيد.
يمكن أن يستمر مولر في أداء وظيفته دون أي
تدخل أعتقد أنه يقوم بعمل جيد
وكل شيء عن mccabe
ومعالجة مكتب التحقيقات الفدرالي للملف ليس
له علاقة بالتحقيق الروسي
بشأن السيد.  ميلر ، هل أنت قلق من
أن الرئيس يستعد لإصدار
أمر بإقالة مولر ، فمن المؤكد أنه يبدو بهذه
الطريقة من تغريداته كما قلت من
قبل إذا حاول القيام بذلك ،
فسيكون ذلك بداية نهاية
رئاسته لأننا نحكم.
لما رأيته في مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
ووزارة العدل فيما يتعلق
بالملف أزعجني حقًا ، فقد كان مستندًا سياسيًا مدفوع الأجر
لم يتم التحقق من استخدامه
بشكل غير لائق من قبل المحكمة ، وكان عميلان من مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي يحققان مع كلينتون متحيزين
ضد ترامب لصالح كلينتون كل
ما يحتاجه  ليتم النظر فيها لهذا السبب
أريد مستشارًا خاصًا ثانيًا منفصلًا
ولكن عندما يتعلق الأمر بالسيد.  مولر هو
يتابع الدليل حيث
يأخذه وأعتقد أنه من المهم جدًا
أن يُسمح له بأداء وظيفته دون
تدخل وهناك العديد من
الجمهوريين الذين يشاركوني وجهة نظري